the swift collapse of afghanistan's
american trained military forces has put
the biden administration on the
defensive insisting it's not abandoning
the afghan government and its people but
as the taliban move closer to kabul
american diplomats are being evacuated
from the u.s embassy as the security
situation worsens by the hour christina
rafini is at the white house with more
on all of this christina good morning to
you
good morning jeff president biden is
away at camp david this morning but
white house aides tell us he is
monitoring the situation in afghanistan
closely meanwhile that situation as you
saw in roxanna's piece is rapidly
devolving with staff at the embassy
being asked to destroy classified
information and anything that could be
used as propaganda including american
flags
with the situation in afghanistan
rapidly devolving
president biden flew to camp david
without commenting but i do not regret
my decision but on tuesday the president
defended his decision to withdraw u.s
military forces after 20 years at war
they've got to fight for themselves
fight for their nation
but over the next 48 hours the fighting
escalated with the taliban rapidly
gaining ground prompting the state
department to announce a drawdown at the
u.s embassy in kabul this is not
abandonment this is not an evacuation
this is not the wholesale withdrawal
and the pentagon announced it's sending
3 000 american troops back into
afghanistan to pull embassy personnel
out we believe this is the prudent thing
to do given
the rapidly deteriorating security
situation
in and around
kabul the state department denies the
embassy is closing or moving to a
fallback location at the heavily secured
airport but when asked about reports of
staff being told to destroy classified
materials a department spokesperson told
cbs news it was part of standard
operating procedure for a diplomatic
drawdown the message we are sending to
the people of afghanistan is
our one of enduring partnership
meanwhile the people of afghanistan can
only watch as the u.s moves out and the
taliban moves in there is no way you can
sit there and say that the people of
afghanistan watching the taliban take
over provinces watching their country
crumble are now going to watch american
diplomats get on military planes and
leave the country that that sends the
signal that the u.s is with them in the
long haul diplomatically this is about
one thing and one thing only it's about
the priority this president attaches to
the safety and security of americans uh
who serve in this government that is not
a priority uh that we are willing to
risk
the state department spokesperson also
pointed to the continued diplomatic and
financial support the u.s has provided
to afghanistan as evidence of that
enduring support for the country now
elaine diplomatic sources tell me
they're not only worried about the
embassy they're now concerned about the
airport and what happens if hundreds of
thousands of afghans start to rush the
flights trying to leave the country if
kabul starts to fall fast-moving
situation christina thank you